[Music]
wake up the white lights calling
of the world is falling
[Music]
I've been hoping
one day we could run away
[Music]
thank you
so we just stand
ing
[Music]
washed out long City Lights
are stronger
[Music]
I'm still a fight
I've been away
with broken glasses
[Music]
we always
foreign
you
doing
[Music]
[Applause]
cool spot right I found that actually
accidentally while I was going to a
completely different Park and I'm glad
that I did because it was a fun place to
uh play around with some point
isolations and patterns so um thank you
for checking that out and an even bigger
thank you to flow toys for sponsoring
this video and giving me a reason to go
out and explore DC and to uh go ahead
and explore my flow every month if you'd
like to grab a set of those flow Mojo
boy that I was using in this video you
can do so by using the promo code
drexfactor 9 2023 that is drexfactor 9
2023 at checkout over at flowtoys.com
that will get you a discount on anything
in the flowtoys store and even better
than that it helps out the channel so
everybody wins thank you once again to
flow toys for sponsoring this video
and speaking of thank yous I owe some
thank yous to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel That is Becca Beck London thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission also this
video would not be possible we're not
for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people to sit down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently supporter but
you'd like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring horse spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to check out more of my flow videos
I will include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube thanks so much for
watching I hope that you get outside to
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care now
peace
[Music]